okay what if we open our techies what is
like this no matter what game you play
there's something you hate playing
against that's the exact same line we
used in what is Teemo okay okay what
about something like this sometimes you
hate something not because it's good but
because it shouldn't be that was also in
Teemo did you even watch the Teemo
episode you know I don't give a [__]
about our league content whatever I'm
out of ideas
we shouldn't have wasted such a great
intro on that blow darting a little
bastard [__] it let's just reuse the
lines it's not like anyone's gonna
notice anyway sometimes you play against
a monster and it's techies perfect
techies the name alone evokes a certain
kind of reaction tickets rip and pepper
all God on top of being the most rage
inspiring character in dota techies is
the troll pick that all others wish they
could be so what exactly is this hero
and why is it such a nightmare
[Music]
well originally known as the Goblin
techies and DOTA allstars
techies is made up of three dobby like
demolition obsessed delinquents by the
names of squeezed spleens and spindle
the trio are notorious for carting
themselves around the map deploying
invisible traps and voice lines in
equally infuriating measure what makes
techies the ultimate troll pick though
is the fact that no matter how many
times the hero gets reworked its purpose
has remained the same to ruin your
opponent's enjoyment of dota if you
don't believe me just look at their
proximity mines stasis traps
[Music]
self-destruction mechanic
or better yet there remote-detonated
barrels of despair with devastating
tools like these at their disposal
techies players are equipped to make
sure that enemy teams can't ward gank
push or really move at all without the
worry of being blown to smithereens
[Music]
as if that wasn't truly enough the hero
even has a minefield sign that can be
placed anywhere on the map it can either
be set down randomly as a decoy or once
upgraded with agony meant underlying
traps from being revealed goddamn I knew
he was still there and it's because of
the constant anxiety it causes the
techies has solidified itself not only
as BM inducing [__] but also was one
of the highest skill cap characters in
the game
no anyway for a long time the go to
community regarded techies as nothing
more than a meme pic it was one of the
last heroes from the original dota to be
added in the dota 2 and when it was
finally unveiled at ti4 s all-star match
it drew rapturous applause
[Applause]
this is how Liberty dies it's under
surplus while fans in the crowd were
unsure of techies viability it wasn't
long before a small group of players
began to discover just how dangerous the
hero can be one of those players was
Alexander robot vice dagger you know you
can do ten thousand damage in one second
which no other hero could do that dota
and people just don't like playing
against it because you're playing your
regular game of dota and all sudden you
just die and you don't have any chance
of surviving now if getting [__] for
being PPD's brother wasn't enough robot
vice decide to make life even harder for
himself by grinding to become a
high-level tech he's main I've always
like enjoyed like being different and
when the hero came out I started playing
it and I just realized it was like
entirely different than playing regular
dota you get to play your own game you
know you kind of just do your own thing
and you can win the game for your team
and I really enjoy that
[Music]
you were one sick puppy while techies
was seen as an annoying paranoia
sparking pests in pubs the hero was
mostly irrelevant at the pro level the
only player to really acknowledge the
threat that techies carried at the time
was Iggy's Curtis Ali mm Ling a big
brain support player equally known for
his designer Snuggies shut up and take
my money anyway now we didn't just
recognize techies strength he was
terrified by it so much so that two
months before TI 5 he started a petition
to remove the hero from the game to save
dota when his cries went ignored how he
decided something needed to be done to
prove his point
so prior to TI 5 he enlisted the help of
robot vice to become the very thing he
hated most a techie spammer I think Ally
he's always like been really good at
being like analytical about the game and
he understands concepts and strategies
that a lot of people would never even
understand I think he's very smart very
intelligent about dota he definitely
understood the skill ceiling on this
hero was so high and that it just
changed dota entirely away from what
everyone loves with robot vices guidance
how he developed his tackies game and
when TI rolled around
he made it painfully clear to everyone
that the hero was no joke well techie
what advantages do you really see and
hold up top playing aggressive these
gonna be dumped down the suicide is
there this time see that kissing you're
gonna play around we're gonna make just
enough heads up there there goes the
visoreds bikini runs right into that you
hate techies I do hate techies when the
heroes in the game only he's having fun
that's how I feel about it
and did you have fun playing of course
is super fun alleys techies proved to be
so effective that later in the
tournament teams began removing it from
EJ's hero pool during the first banning
phase the fact that no one's practicing
against this hero because no one's
picking in scrims
so all sudden this hero shows up you
know on the main stage at the biggest
tournament eSports what do you do do you
try to play against it you'd have no
idea how to play against it you haven't
practiced against it what do you do this
powerful pocket pick gave eg a tactical
edge entering drafts and it showed in
Grand Finals when the hero drew bans
from CDC in all four games that's right
without even being played that series
the goblin trio helped Ali and eg to
secure North America's first ever ti
title
[Applause]
upon seeing techies impact on eSports
biggest stage valve immediately issued
nerfs to the hero which led to a
significant rework by the end of 2016
while techies does occasionally get
played in pubs for trolling purposes
more than anything
devout practitioners like robot vice
remain optimistic that the hero still
has a place at the highest level I think
we're gonna see techies a few games at
TI I don't think it's nearly as broken
as it used to be but I still think it is
entirely abusable if you are at that
skill ceiling like at least close to the
top of that skill ceiling if there's one
thing that pakis has taught us it's that
the unknown should be feared that every
tool has a purpose and that sometimes
even a disarming joke can be turned into
a powerful weapon
die [__] man you'd have to be a real
[__] to get tricked by a techies I
thought dota players were supposed to be
smart
[__] would never happen to me who put
this stupid sign here you probably
should have took you really done it now
attack ease if there's one thing the
techies has taught us it's that I can't
fake it back beep [__] it [__] it let's
just reuse the lines it's not like
anyone's gonna
[Laughter]
[Music]